I have a question about the warrior
mentality I recently was dumped on a
deployment and it's difficult now that I
am home
stateside how does a warrior handle this
is it like any other emotional loss I'm
trying to use this loss and get after it
and improve myself mentally and
physically I'm not sure how to properly
submit questions to the podcast all
right so the Dear John letter the old
classic Dear John letter and so you know
agree sometimes you can keep it at bay
when you're deployed but then when you
get home and you get back to the places
the familiar places where you have the
met specific memories that's that's
where the pain start to come in and
that's fine you know that's that hurts
that's we get that but in my opinion
I've said this before the person that
you built in your mind the person that
you had a relationship with that you
built in your mind that person doesn't
actually exist they're not real they're
not real she wasn't who she appeared to
be and she isn't who she appeared to be
she isn't the sweet understanding fun
person that you cared so much about
that's not her that's your memory that's
what you built in your head she is
actually the selfish self-centered
person that cares about herself first
and doesn't care about you that's the
reality and that's fine but a lot of
times the pain that we feel isn't based
on the reality it's based on the fantasy
so you're feeling pain of losing
something that wasn't real so let the
fantasy go remember that she is not the
perfect person that you built in your
mind period she's not otherwise we
wouldn't be in this situation right now
and then move on brother get after it
work out train hard go to jujitsu hike
run of play guitar just get after it
and those things not only gonna distract
from the pain which is good they're
gonna improve you as a human being which
is good and they're to rebuild your
confidence which is good they're gonna
make you feel good they're gonna make
you stronger and smarter and better and
put you into a place where you don't
need that little made-up fantasy anymore
and they're gonna put you in a place
we're gonna find something badder than
the fantasy now I'm gonna tell you right
now the fantasies don't exist the
perfect girl or guy for you doesn't
exist
they don't exist so you're gonna be out
looking for someone that's good but
you're not gonna find perfect don't get
obsessed with finding perfect if you
find someone that's perfect it's not
true everyone's got their flaws so
that's what you have to do and you will
end up finding someone that's real and I
get it man I know you're gonna have some
moments down in the hole as Alison
chains put it or trapped in the
heart-shaped box as Nirvana put it or so
lonesome you could cry as Hank Williams
senior put it is that you notice a theme
here this is what people go through but
those feelings of they're temporary so
let them say hi let them hang around for
a minute or for half an hour or an hour
or whatever and then kick them out kick
those feelings out get them out of there
and go do something else
take your mind away from those memories
of fantasies and put build some good
memories that are real then yeah you
know what you can use your anger and
your frustration to fuel positivity for
sure I spent much of my youth doing that
very thing for sure all those breakups
yeah I turned those things into in the
fuel
and the other thing I'm gonna use if if
you take action with your body your
minds gonna follow and pretty soon
you'll be on to the next chapter and you
can move beyond this bad fantasy chapter
that you kind of got roped into girls
man I can teach you every time if you
let him it's so hard to I'm with there's
so many times you know because when I
was a assistant platoon commander
platoon commander at asking the
commander what I was doing right but
more in the earlier phases right because
once I was you know what to ask you to
commander I was dealing with a lot less
those those problems that would come to
me on a relationship level would be
something big you know divorce custody
of children yeah some kind of domestic
violence scenario like real things but
when I was younger and I was in a seal
platoon that's when you're dealing with
guys going through the breakup with the
girl and that you know the method
messing with my head yeah it's messing
with my head man yeah of course
every guy goes through that me you ever
that's the way it is you get that weird
thing kicking around in there and you
start getting crazy and what's so funny
is what's so funny is when you're on the
outside of it it's so like when you're
in the heart-shaped box yourself and you
just can't see anything else it's just
devastating and everyone that's looking
at you is like bro let's just go to the
bargain night you meet 17 new girls
tonight
yeah but I fight back no it's not I
remember I kind of had a this is kind of
evil but I had a kind of a standard
response to guys when they'd say you
know hey you know I broke up with
Jennifer last night I made sweet man
let's let's roll
I would always and I even carried that
honestly this is like not something I
don't think I do anymore but even when
guys who would be like came in me and
Jennifer getting divorced I back oh
right on bro that's let's rock and roll
you know I kind of and part of it was
just to kind of spin it like guys man
it's not that you need to you know you
don't just wallow in it right you're
getting divorced okay here's what you
needed to do here's how you maneuver but
you know what are you gonna do you're
gonna get dragged down by that into that
mire or you're gonna you know salvage
what you can of your life and let's move
on let's rock and roll
yeah so that's again it might be a
little harsh I don't know that I would
still have that react maybe with maybe
fall still in the Jews you know and most
and 99 I had one guy that that that in I
probably said that too we have a high
divorce rate in the single team so yeah
ii 85 90 percent divorce rate so I've
said this to quite a few individuals
over there I only had one that ever kind
of you know was was like no man you
don't get it and then I said no I said
you get it mmm you don't get it
yeah and it always is a little rougher
when there's kids involved and all that
so that would put another little
horrible spin on it but the bottom line
is that is a good attitude to have
hey broke up with my girl right on I'm
glad I got out of this relationship
before it developed into something where
I did have hooks in me financial hooks
children yeah all those things I made it
out scot-free you know I'm getting
divorced
oh you have any kids no okay rock and
roll yeah you got kids okay well how's
it gonna go you know what are you put in
line yeah you know so yeah definitely
hard here's the question have you ever
gotten your heart broken
a negative you haven't straight-up even
of course I I was I was a boy boys get
their heart broken
win-win tell me you know 10 11 I'm 21
ish time cuz you know when you're 10
it's like okay 15 14 17 13 I mean I
think once I was obscene once I was in
the SEAL Teams that kind of had that
coping mechanism yeah yeah gotta be hard
yeah and the girls are like mmm yeah you
know you gotta you gotta just kind of
but the other young that's you know the
younger days for sure every guy goes
through that and that's what that's
what's hard and you know what I'm saying
guys specifically but the girls are the
same way both guys and girls go through
these two horrible breakups when you and
and and this is the other thing that we
got to realize as parents when you're 16
years old
we you know I look at my 15 16 17 year
old daughters right as they were growing
up
and and I think oh they got a boyfriend
whatever he'll be this guy is
meaningless in their lives i factually
know that these guys are meaningless in
terms of the broad spectrum of their
life yeah but guess what when you're 15
years old and you got a boyfriend that
is your whole life yeah and so when
something goes sideways I had to say oh
I had to remember that myself when I saw
my daughter's distraught over something
I'd say okay here's what's going on this
is her whole life and I tried to explain
to him this guy I understand that you
like him and then he was good and blah
blah blah but you know let's remember
you're only 15 and there you know you're
gonna meet another nice guy and other
there'll be other opportunities and blah
blah blah but the of course it barely
barely gets through to their head yeah
belief they can't even imagine and no
certain is different I know because he's
the best no and so yeah yeah you're
you're on that question restriction from
now on no bail I wanted her to know I
think we all wanted to know